[Music]
Shawn and kamila sitting courtside in
their seats ki SS I and G Wow this all
went down at Monday night's Clippers
game in Los Angeles
and guys they did not hold back on the
PDA she was holding his face he was
kissing her cheek she was kissing his
pant and they were full-on making out
where's the kiss cam when you need it
most
now are we surprised by this blatant
display of affection no I think if
you're smooching you got it smooch like
you're in a rom-com I love that you want
to smooch like you're in a boring drama
she has a point so we we saw like on
Twitter and stuff you guys saying stuff
about the way we're kissing and out
looks weird like we kiss like fish yeah
and really hurt our feelings we just
want to show you how you really kiss
yeah
another reason why we shouldn't be
surprised that video which by the way
Shawn has deleted off his Instagram and
I don't understand why that video exists
forever
we just factually how you really kiss
yeah what we will say the bear has come
leaps and bounds from trying to keep the
romance quiet remember this yeah they
went from not wanting to talk about it
to packing on the PDA everywhere like
this with you and Shawn as well I mean
you guys just look so happy at a moment
is that the case yeah we're pretty happy
I really really loved him a lot
you heard that right you guys just look
so happy at a moment is that the case
yeah we're pretty happy I really really
love him a lot we love him a lot look
now Camilla is gearing up to release her
second solo album and we're thinking
that we're gonna get some more Shawn
inspired songs
[Music]
my songs have always been personal like
even the last album because I'm writing
them so they're my stories but I think
that it's just a lot more detailed
because I'm living a lot more so here's
hoping for that new album sooner rather
than later and also more pics like this
alright guys that is it for today for
all the latest on Shambhala stick with
all things
edie until next time I'm Katie Krauss
and bye for now
[Music]